[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 sport sur
tv 78 voici les titres de ce 13 novembre
samedi soir le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a vibré pour
ses champions de boxe retour sur cette
soirée notamment sur la victoire de
l'élan courtois a dit lahm ou mady qui
conserve sa ceinture européenne des
poids super moyens en rugby deuxième
victoire consécutive pour montigny le
bretonneux un succès acquis à domicile
face à reims le club remonte en milieu
de classement loin néanmoins du podium
et puis nous parlerons aussi judo tout à
l'heure avec vous rassure le président
du comité des yvelines dans quelques
jours l'agglomération saint-quentinoise
accueillera les championnats de france
incertain heavy rain heures pourraient
faire le déplacement à la boxe était
donc à l'honneur au vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines avec le
mini 24 une première dans cette enceinte
au programme douze combats avec en point
d'orgue les lans courtois a dit lahm ou
mady qui a défendu avec brio sa ceinture
de champion d'europe
même si le suspense est resté entier
tout au long du combat nicolas d'andrine
nicolas quere le vix montrer sous
artifices pour un combat explosif
l'élan courtois a dit la môme a dit
était très attendue pour ce gala de boxe
organisé au vélodrome nationale à
domicile le boxeur de 37 ans n'a pas
déçu ses supporters
face à un adversaire solide le champion
en titre a dû livrer un combat acharné
pour remporter la victoire
une victoire finalement acquise au front
après la limite et qui lui permet de
conserver son titre de champion d'europe
dans la catégorie des poids super moyens
[Musique]
champion d'europe dans les yvelines
grande fierté et encore merci pour ceux
qui me soutiennent fierté un objectif
terminer on est parti pour d'autres
objectifs encore le mans à domicile le
champion d'europe a bénéficié d'un
soutien sans faille de ses proches
encouragements écrit ils étaient plus
d'une cinquantaine présents autour du
ring et y avoir beaucoup de serre en
face christophe était présent ce soir et
il nous importe aujourd'hui c'est écrit
là et garde sa ceinture est la grèce je
le remercie c'est quelqu'un de courageux
on retient une belle du corps battu là
c'était un beau combat ce soir et je
pense que tout le monde apprécie il
boxait eux aussi à domicile les membres
de la team farrugia des longs cours
termine avec un bilan positif
marvin petit a décroché une 22e victoire
en poids super légers et gallus coulon a
remporté lui sa huitième victoire chez
les super légers
c'est vraiment une déjà une belle salle
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ça fait vraiment plaisir de boxer chez
nous devant notre public on a je pense
qu'on était tous transcender quelques
quelques bords de boxe ici
seul bémol de la soirée la défaite aux
points de marine tollé pour son premier
combat professionnel
au total pour ce premier gala de boxe
organisé au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines 12 combats étaient
organisées durant toute la soirée de
quoi satisfaire les 6000 spectateurs
dans un bel endroit je pense
progressivement
la structure mouchoirs c'est top il n'y
a pas de gros événements qui se passent
au vélodrome des événements sportifs
donc là si c'est vraiment une belle
événements et il faut que ça continue
simplement changement de style et
changement d'ambiance le week-end
prochain le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera le
championnat de france seniors de judo
[Musique]
il y avait du rugby également ce week
end et dimanche en promotion d'honneur
montigny le bretonneux recevait à reims
le club local la 7e ne devait pas
concéder de nouvelle défaite sous peine
de s'approcher dangereusement de la zone
de relégation l'équipe senior a bien
réagi nicolas landry deuxième victoire
de suite pour montigny le bretonneux
un succès face à reims construit sur une
bonne entame de match désigné montrent
un suite à un ballon perdu par les
rémois le demi de mêlée récupère il
esquive un plaquage avant de transmettre
aux 12
le trois quarts centre fixe le dernier
défenseur et donne au numéro ans pour
marquer le premier essai de la partie
montigny récidive sur un lancement de
jeu après une mêlée cette fois ci le 15
décale son ailier pour inscrire un
doublé
et quelques minutes plus tard on
retrouve le 15 à la baguette l'arrière
transperce la défense
tape à suivre récupère et inscrire un
troisième essai après 20 minutes de jeu
montigny mène 22 à 0
on a fait sur 25 superbe bonnes
premières minutes
et puis après on a remis l'adversaire
dans le match commencé à faire des
fautes ont mal joué au pied et puis
l'adversaire est revenue des plaquages
ratés des erreurs techniques et une
domination des avants les mois plus
costaud montigny concède deux essais
reims revient à cinq points des minimes
ont atteint 22 à 17 à la pause les
rémois entament la seconde période sur
le même rythme multiplication des fautes
beaucoup de tension entre les deux
équipes
larbitre distribuer plusieurs cartons 2
pour montigny un seul pour reims lésigny
montain parviennent à se mettre à l'abri
en inscrivant une pénalité
le score n'évoluera plus 25 17 pour les
vert et blanc sanogo parce que l'année
dernière on avait on n'avait pas connu
la défaite en ont fait trois défaites
directs d'entrée alors qu'en par deux
victoires donc on espère que ça va
continuer
prochaine rencontre dimanche prochain
face au dernier de cette poule de
promotion honneur
saint-andré-les-vergers dans le reste de
l'actualité sportive des yvelines où il
s'est qualifié pour le 8e tour de la
coupe de france de football
qualification 1-0 face à bretteville la
dernière fois que le club avait atteint
ce niveau c'était en 1940 et puis en
basket strap s'est fait surprendre à
domicile lors de la 7e journée de
national 3 quand l'emportent 2 6 points
et reste sur le podium devant l'équipe
locale et qui aura l'occasion néanmoins
de se relancer dès la semaine prochaine
lors d'un déplacement chez la lanterne
rouge
evreux voici le classement de cette
nationale 3 et de cette poule g en
basket basket hommes et puis en
badminton le club de montigny le
bretonneux vient d'organiser son
traditionnel tournoi annuel
le sky bad pour cette neuvième édition
300 participants étaient présents au
gymnase pierre de coubertin pierre de
coubertin pardon à 2000 euros de lots
étaient à rafler pour les différents
vainqueurs les matchs ne s'effectuer
qu'en double je reçois à présent et
christophe manas un bonsoir mon spi
recteur technique national de la
fédération française 2
glisse mme à fin octobre se déroulait
les championnats d'europe de cyclisme
sur piste à berlin la france termine à
la deuxième place avec cinq médailles
d'or une d'argent et deux de bronze
l'allemagne décroche 12 médailles et se
trouve donc en première place
est ce que c'est un bon bilan pour les
français oui c'est un très bon bilan
puisque les championnats d'europe sont
une compétition de début de saison pour
les pisteurs donc on est allé pour
valider un peu le travail effectué à
l'entraînement et effectivement on a des
eu des très bonnes surprises et l'équipe
de france et est au rendez vous alors
c'est mieux qu'en 2016 c'était à saint
quentin en yvelines d'ailleurs au
vélodrome pour la précédente édition
c'est mieux en terme de médailles mais
la france n'est au moins avait terminé à
la première place au classement
oui il faut juste comparer ce qui est
comparable alors on voit avec les bons
résultats des allemands que
concourir à domicile c'est un avantage
mais surtout en allemagne tous les
championnats d'europe post
olympiques sont parfois un peu déprécié
dont il ya vraiment il y avait un très
bon niveau dans ces championnats
d'europe 2010 est est vraiment la
performance de l'équipe de france a été
très bonne est meilleure que l'année
passée d'abord il ya surtout des
médailles chez les hommes un peu moins
chez les femmes ça s'explique comment ça
s'explique
le côté féminin et notre notre point
faible on a évidemment mathilde de gros
qui est qui nous éclairent de cinq à
sept ses progrès tous les jours
exceptionnels mais voilà derrière on a
un petit peu de
un petit peu de difficulté à constituer
des équipes
donc voilà c'est notre piste de
progression de de refaire une belle
équipe de france féminine il ya des
athlètes qui sont là qui ont du
potentiel
bon à nous de les faire progresser
à nous également d'aller chercher une
détecter de nouvelles sportives
notamment pour les jo de paris 2024 ces
championnats d'europe ont permis aussi
de faire tomber des records nationaux je
parle pour la france et sur les
résultats qui ont été obtenus c'est pour
ça que vous avez souligné que c'était de
bons championnats d'europe pour l'équipe
de france il ya des nouveaux talents qui
ont émergé justement à lors de cette
compétition sachant que les anciens on
va dire n'était pas sélectionné donc
alors les anciens évidemment sont
toujours membre du pôle france ils
s'entraînent ils font partie de l'équipe
de france donc après une période un peu
tumultueuse qui a été juste après les jo
tout s'est mis en place on l'a repris
l'entraînement sur de bonnes doses dont
les anciens avec coupure de quelques
mois n'était pas compétitif sur ce
championnat
donc ça nous a permis d'essayer de
des jeunes coin de laisser leur chance
aux jeunes coureurs et là on a vu là on
a vraiment vu des bons résultats avec
des environs qui ont la poursuite
olympique était vraiment exceptionnel a
fait un bon temps vous avez dit le
record de france
et puis sébastien vigier au mathilde
jeune et déjà cité on a on a un bel
avenir devant nous pour 2020 et alors on
va parler de cet avenir et puis aussi
revenir un petit peu en arrière sur
votre prise de fonction puisqu'on va
revenir à présent sur vos premiers mois
en tant que directeur technique national
vous avez succédé à vincent jacquey à
qui l'on a reproché l'impossibilité de
trouver un accord sur la vision de la
mise en place du projet sportif de la
fédération française de cyclisme
c'est le président de la ffc qui le
disaient aujourd'hui est ce que vous
vous avez le sentiment d'être en phase
alors l'actualité fait que dans deux
jours je vais présenter le travail
permanent de la commission nationale du
sport de haut niveau ce qu'on appelle un
pépé est un plan de performance fédéral
donc c'est en quelque sorte ma politique
sportive
2010cette jusqu'à 2024 cette politique
sportive je les écris avec avec des
cadres de la fédération mais surtout en
accord avec le projet fédéral du
président de callot donc on peut dire
que la hausse étant d'accord venez en
accord et pour bien fonctionner dans un
poste de dtn il est important d'être
d'être raccord avec avec la politique
sportive des élus c'était peut-être plus
le cas jugé sain voilà voilà en tout cas
je m'inscris bien dans le projet fédéral
et voilà je gse ce document se ppf prêt
à présenter au ministère dès jeudi et
dans les grandes lignes
que contient ce document alors
préférentiels non dans les grandes
lignes
donc c'est notre stratégie dans les
grandes lignes le le mot clé du
programme c'est de savoir rouler vite et
savoir rouler vite le jour j donc on
s'aperçoit que si on prend les modèles
de performance donc c'est à dire la lah
modèle de performance c'est un peu la
recette qui permet de de performer dans
chaque discipline il est important de
rouler vite
ça peut être roulé vite dans la première
ligne droite en bmx a peut être roulé
vite dans un contre la montre sur la
route
évidemment où les vite sur la piste on
s'aperçoit que s'est déroulée à une
grande vitesse donc il ya un travail à
faire sur l'aérodynamisme et l'un d'eux
d'éléments comme ça et donc tout le
programme est articulé de cette
manière-là avec la formation des jeunes
coureurs et puis après la montée en
puissance et jusque dans les dernières
les dernières lignes droites
la préparation mentale et tout ce qui a
pu manquer à l'équipe de france
peut-être six dernières années
vous parliez justement ces difficultés
de aussi au niveau du mental aujourd'hui
le climat est apaisé on l'a mentionné
très rapidement ses difficultés à
l'issue des derniers jeux olympiques
détention aussi aujourd'hui avec le
dialogue avec tous les coureurs et
apaisée oui je vous confirme que tout se
passe bien les et alors là là on parle
des sprinteurs donc tout le monde a fait
et hélas pour la rentrée en septembre
donc du pôle sprint ici à saint quentin
tout se passe bien il ya deux
entraîneurs qui qui se partagent le
travail qui se partagent l'équipe
tout va bien on a évidemment il n'y a
pas de pression pour l'instant voilà on
se bat pas pour des sélections comme le
champion d'europe s'est pas c'est pas la
sélection du geo mais tous les voyants
sont au vert pour que ça se passe bien
et qu'on puisse travailler sereinement
en tout cas moi j'ai tenu à affirmer à
tout ce qu' on était vraiment dans un
objectif collectif et que c'était
l'équipe qui déprimait l'équipe de
france et je voulais pas avoir de ma
d'ambitions personnelles ou enfin
viennent parasiter l'ambiance si je
passais dans le passé lors des
précédentes olympiades notamment vous
avez été cycliste professionnel vous
même c'est quoi le style aujourd'hui à
christophe malin ça vous sert justement
cette expérience professionnelle cette
expérience elles me servent dans le sens
que je connais un peu le sujet du vélo
donc j'ai fait de la route et j'ai fait
du vtt
bon j'ai évidemment fait toutes les
autres disciplines en formation mais le
pour moi il sera plus mon style c'est
surtout je l'espère c'est au niveau du
management
j'ai dans mes posts précédents j'ai été
formé au coaching
voilà je suis très intéressé par le par
le management et il me semble que c'est
ce qui manquait peut-être à l'équipe
précédente donc c'est ce que je
m'efforce de faire notamment avec
quelque chose d'assez nouveau yahia j'ai
créé une corde au avec des managers
depuis hier et on travaille
régulièrement toutes les semaines on a
une réunion et voilà c'est un peu
ce groupe là qui dirige d'un parti au
niveau de la fédération et en fait ça de
manière collégiale en rassemblant les
disciplines et en décidant tous ensemble
des budgets des orientations je vous ai
parlé du ppf nous avons écrit ensemble
donc voilà c'est plutôt ça mon style que
une toute dernière question est ce que
l'équipe de france de cyclisme doit être
ambitieuse pour 2020 et surtout pour
2024 puisqu'on le sait les jeux
olympiques se dérouleront notamment à
saint quentin en yvelines
alors évidemment on nous demande dans le
tpf on me demande d'avancer des chiffres
donc effectivement on est ambitieux moi
j'ai le ministère a conscience que avec
les 22 titres qui si on additionne
premier titre que le que l'équipe de
france de cyclisme points et pau et
enfin pour les gagner mais voilà on fait
partie des fédérations qui compte dans
le paysage français on est avec les
points que nous avons
soit déjà déjà incapable de gagner soit
des personnes qui vont monter en
puissance
on est vraiment ambitieux et donc il
faut l'être pour 2024 puisque une fois
de plus ces jeux olympiques se
dérouleront à saint quentin en yvelines
pour partie merci dupont 2020 ou pas
sonné 2020 bien sûr se refermer travaux
de restauration merci christophe manas
directeur technique national de cette
fédération nationale de cyclisme
merci à vous il marque une pause dans ce
set 8 sport pour évoquer une discipline
ancestrale à cette année les journées
nationales de chasse au vol se tenait
dans les yvelines événement organisé en
partenariat avec le département les
images les explications de maxime le
maine
[Musique]
des fauconniers venus de toute la france
s'étaient donné rendez vous cette année
dans les yvelines pour les journées
nationales de chasse au vol
un événement organisé en partenariat
avec le département
nous sommes ravis les avoir accueillis
sur tout le territoire des yvelines ça a
été une façon pour nous aussi de montrer
la richesse de notre territoire à la
fois nos plaines et mais à la fois aussi
nos forêts et c'est une occasion de
mettre aussi en avant cette chasse qui
est classé au patrimoine immatériel de
l'unesco
en france près de 400 personnes
pratiquent cette chasse atypique
ce sont des passionnés ce sont des gens
qui depuis 1954 ont décidé de ré
implantées en france une chasse ce qui
est ancestrale puisqu'elle est même
moyenâgeuse et même on va pouvoir dire
presque égyptienne on distingue deux
types de chasse la chasse de haut vol et
la chasse de bavol la chasse de ba vol
c'est l'oiseau est sur le banc et on est
en quête enquête on cherche le gibier
sur le territoire mesloise on reste sur
le banc un peu comme un fusil et quand
on lève un gibier ou le chien lève un
gibier là on laisse partir l'oiseau qui
va faire un sprint donc ça peut être 100
m 200 m pour pouvoir capturer son gibier
survol consiste à faire évoluer un donc
un faucon comme vous l'avez vu en
altitude le plus haut possible en
fonction des possibilités et disposition
dans la plaine de fer qui étaient à un
chien le chien va arrêter un gibier on
va faire lever le gibier et c'est à ce
moment là que le mouvement du vivier qui
va s'envoler va déclencher une attaque
une fois le gibier attraper le chasseur
laisse l'oiseau en manger un morceau
récompense indispensable une marque de
respect du chasseur à son équipier qui
rappelons le est un animal sauvage non
dressé obéissant à ses instincts raison
d'ailleurs pour lesquels beaucoup de
fauconniers estime pratique et la plus
naturelle des chasses retour à saint
quentin en yvelines avec dans un instant
tous les détails de la prochaine grande
compétition de judo qui se déroulera
dans quelques jours sur le territoire
auparavant saviez vous que des séances
de sport pourrait être prescrite sur
ordonnance prochainement l'agglomération
a rejoint le réseau sport santé
ordonnance lancée en 2012 par le docteur
alexandre feltz à strasbourg réseau qui
compte déjà une soixantaine de communes
membres au niveau national les acteurs
du projet sur saint-quentin là doivent
être encore ciblé qu'il s'agisse des
médecins généralistes ou encore des
associations
du côté des patients on sait que ceux
atteints d'une affection de longue durée
d'une maladie respiratoire par exemple
seront concernés ce dispositif vient
d'être lancé en fin de semaine dernière
et c'était une nouvelle fois au
vélodrome
je pense que ça va se passer comme dans
toutes les autres villes c'est à dire
que il faut mobiliser les médecins
généralistes parce que c'est eux qui
sont en contact avec la population on va
définir le type de maladie diabète
cancer hypertension maladies
respiratoires stabiliser et puis on va
créer un lieu de coordination peut-être
ici ou dans un autre centre où les
éducateurs vont recevoir les personnes
malades veulent l'agglomération s'engage
à faciliter la coordination entre les
différents acteurs de ce de ce
dispositif notamment pour la
communication notamment pour la mise à
disposition de ressources humaines pour
la gestion du dispositif pour permettre
éventuellement aussi de mettre des
locaux à disposition et pour permettre
de gérer au mieux avec les ressources
humaines nécessaires
le dispositif santé sur ordonnance et
les questions de judo à présent avec
vous offre en bourasseau bienvenus en
plateau vous êtes le président président
non je vais corriger l'erreur que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure et que je viens de
refaire conseiller technique pour le
comité a départementale donc des des
yvelines de judo on va parler du
championnat de france qui va se tenir au
vélodrome de saint quentin ce sera le 18
et 19 novembre un mois auparavant
forcément de cette performance de teddy
riner cent trente huit victoires
d'affilée aucune défaite depuis sept ans
et ce week end
cent trente neuvième victoire nouveau
titre de champion du monde elle la
décima le 10e c'est une machine teddy
riner bat ça c'est le c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire une belle vitrine pour
la discipline
abate 10 a encore une fois frappé un
et on est ravi de sa performance à toute
la fédération qui est derrière lui c'est
un athlète qui est relativement constant
les dans les résultats et qui montre
encore une fois que le travail paye et
sa régularité à l'entraînement montre
qu'aujourd'hui ben c'est quelqu'un de
très performant quoi est-ce qu'il sera
présent pour le championnat de france la
transition et ont trouvé puisqu'il est
annoncé alors normalement au tpiy
de participer au championnat de france
simplement je crois que il va avoir le
droit de se reposer parce qu'elle a
rempli un objectif plus que plus
qu'intéressant donc normalement il n'est
pas à 100 c'est combattre des pour être
présent pour en tout cas encourager ses
camarades c'est différent camarades de
cette équipe de france les différents
français qui seront présent puisqu'il
aura deux des têtes d'affiché aussi
qu'ils seront présents et présente pour
cette compétition quelques noms penin on
a des athlètes qui ont été sélectionnés
aux jeux olympiques ont acquis leanne le
blouch marc et cyril maret on va avoir
toutes là tout le taf si le saf féminin
des grandes pointures du judo qui vont
s'affronter justement pour j allais dans
le dans la dent dans le nouveau système
mis en place aujourd'hui puisque
aujourd'hui on a on a été on a en
nouveaux responsables de national qui
était au nom de stéphane traîneau qui va
justement il doit prendre les rênes de
cette équipe de france pour la mener au
plus haut niveau
paris 2024 les 840 meilleurs judokas du
pays seront présents ont eu une grosse
compétition d'envergure
il ya des enjeux sur le plan sportif ya
des enjeux sur le département aussi
alors on a pour nous donc en fait donc
déjà pour on a on a seize athlètes du
département qui participent à ce
championnat on a des grands clubs qui
bien sûr
prône le sport de haut niveau et donc la
leucose de sartrouville poissy mantes la
jolie maul le perray en yvelines dont
ces clubs ajustements au mit ont des
athlètes qui vont participer donc on
espère qu'ils vont atteindre le plus
haut niveau de cet niveau de compétition
et bien sûr c'est un enjeu qui a été un
petit peu un peu spéciale puisque en
fait au départ cette condition ne devait
pas se dérouler au vélodrome elle devait
se dérouler à pierre de coubertin à
paris
simplement les calendriers n'ont pas été
suffisamment bien coordonnée et on s'est
retrouvé donc sans structure est
justement la fédération française de
judo m'a demandé si je pouvais organiser
ce championnat en début septembre
donc je dois remercier un peu tout et
tous les élus départ du de laski et
toutes les villes qui nous ont soutenus
dans cette aventure rien ah oui ils sont
vraiment mobilisés même conseil
départemental qui s'est mis en action
sur des cons qui sait sur des temps qui
sont très courts avec une compétition
qui se déroulera sur deux jours le
samedi et le dimanche compétition 9h à
19h30 les catégories on va pas donner
tout le programme mais en tout cas les
qualités
et puis les holdings les plus hauts ce
sera pour le dimanche avec 5000
personnes attendues puisque c'est la
capacité est possible de ce vélodrome
les réservations sont bien passées oui
ça ça démarre plutôt pas mal même c'est
même très fort donc on espère que ça va
continuer parce qu'on n'a pas chez 1
on n'a pas fait un coût très élevé de
l'entrée on a 10 euros donc c'est que
relativement arrêts pour les moins de 16
ans exactement la gratuité pour les
moins de 6 ans une dernière série de
questions parlé tout à l'heure teddy
riner vitrine judo en france comment se
porte la jud dans les haies mais très
bien très bien on a eu des très bons
résultats je content parce que justement
on à ce sujet dans ce jeu développe là
des politiques sportives et on n'a pas
plus tard qu'il ya quinze jours trois
semaines on a été champion de france par
équipes minimes
on a les meilleurs cadets actuellement
sur l'international on a des noms à
bastien génère jouer prada garrido
alexis gamin super vieille de ces
athlètes qui défendent les couleurs du
département à l'échelle internationale
donc on est pour très très bien et on a
encore eu aussi champion d'île de france
balou vienne dernier des féminines
donc ya pas mal d'espoir pour 2024 ont
parlé cyclisme tout à l'heure en judo
également ah oui oui des représentants
évinois et les 9 et 10 décembre coupe de
france individuel minimaux c'est
exactement alors ça c'est un bel
événement aussi parce que c'est vrai
sale entre 2024 et exactement c'est tous
les athlètes qui sont susceptibles de
pouvoir prétendre à ces deux
compétitions olympiques et il y aura
beaucoup de monde et c'est un bel
événement aussi et on l'annoncera aussi
sur cette antenne merci franck
bourasseau d'être passé en plateau pour
ce 7,8 sport championnats de france qui
se déroulent donc ce week-end de judo
c'est au vélodrome vous voyez la fiche
une nouvelle fois deux autres rendez
vous à noter en sport noter dans vos
agendas du rugby
tout d'abord avec en promotion d'honneur
le sky ruby qui reçoit le rc paris match
à 11% créer un peu plus solidement au
milieu de tableau alors que les leaders
prennent le large dans le classement de
cette promotion d'honneur première poule
et puis la coupe des yvelines de
football avec plusieurs rencontres dès
mercredi notamment celle opposant la
trappe à chevreuse ce sera sur le
terrain de chevreuse et ce sera à partir
de 20 heures et pour refermer cette
édition quelques images très rapidement
de la transat jacques vabre est les
français thomas coville jean luc nélias
ont remporté aujourd'hui à salvador de
bahia la transat jacques vabre dans la
catégorie ultime en sept jours à 22h07
pendant ce temps dans la catégorie imoca
les yvelinois louis burton et servane
escoffier pointe à la quatrième place
le podium est encore possible autre
représentant du département tanguy de
lamotte samantha davies et une sont
actuellement sixièmes ils viennent de
gagner une place prochain est 7,8 sport
ce sera le 20 novembre avec nicolas
kirillovitch en attendant toute
l'actualité sportive est à suivre dans
les différentes éditions du journal à
retrouver aussi bien sur notre antenne
sur notre site internet que sur notre
application mobile très bonne semaine de
sport
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]